good morning Hank it's Tuesday July 7th
and this is not some kind of fancy
camera trick I am really that pale so I
committed to a question Tuesday today
but instead of answering a lot of
questions quickly I'm going to answer a
few questions lengthily but before I do
that I have to change shirts because
right now I match the wall movie magic
with Brotherhood 2.0 initially your idea
or was it Hanks well the initial idea
was mine but it has to be said that I
have a crazy idea at least once every 45
minutes and I count on Hank to be like
that is a terrible idea and when I
pitched him the idea for Brotherhood 2.0
he was like that is not terrible so we
did it what did you do before you became
an author for most of my post college
life I worked at this wonderful magazine
called book list but I also worked as a
hospital chaplain at a Children's
Hospital and I worked at like a Steak
and Shake doing the graveyard shift
which I do not recommend I mean honestly
if anyone is thinking of dropping out of
college get thee to Steak and Shake what
are the best books for aspiring writers
to read as inspiration I'm gonna have to
say my books in fact I'm gonna have to
say that the best way to get inspired to
write is to buy 20 or 30 copies of each
of my books I'm sorry you know once you
finish a book they want you to transform
from an extraordinarily pale nerd who
sits in a basement and writes all day to
some kind of like selling machine so I'm
trying to practice a little bit but
really all I want to do is stay at home
make videos eat peeps and hang out with
Willy what's the meanest thing you ever
did to Hank
hmm I think I'm gonna tried to kill him
with a hammer once when we were little
wait or did he try to kill me
I'm calling mom hey it's John quick
question for you um did I try to kill
Hank with a hammer when I was little he
tried to kill me pwned um did I ever try
to kill Hank in any in any way at all oh
I did shucks what did I specifically do
to try to kill him though I tried to
smother and that's not that's just
hugging that's not killing these are all
very bad behaviors like it's bad to a
poor read cough syrup all over the
bedspread but it's nothing like Hank
trying to murder me with a hammer
well I'm sure I was being irritating but
he tried to kill me with a hammer I feel
like I'm really getting the short end of
the stick here like you're like oh well
he did try to murder you with a hammer
but there was that one time that you
spilled red cough syrup on the bedspread
and then gave him what gave him a big
hug I'm sorry if I tried to smother Hank
by giving him a hug because I loved him
so much and then he tried to kill me
with a hammer okay so there you have it
according to my mom the meanest thing
Hank ever did to me was try to kill me
with a hammer and the meanest thing I
ever did to him was spill some red cough
syrup on his bedspread and then hug him
too hard and yet somehow mom seems to be
making the case that I was somehow the
inferior sibling how often do you get
recognized does it make you feel happy
or slightly awkward I get recognized
pretty often if I'm in a big public
space but it doesn't make me either
happy or slightly awkward it's just kind
of nice to meet a nerdfighter
like the other day I was standing in
line for the Indiana Jones ride at
Disneyland and someone tapped me on the
shoulder and said are you from YouTube
and in his little brother who'd never
heard of nerdfighters looked up at me
and said are you wearing a disguise and
I was like nope these are real what
advice do you have for writers who can't
seem to finish their books not much I
mean it took me four years to finish
Looking for Alaska so I'm clearly not an
expert in the field of finishing just
keep at it can I have one of the
advanced readers copies of Paper Towns
um no because I don't have any in fact
the people who already want advanced
readers copies of Paper Towns are still
waiting for them a situation which I
hope to rectify tomorrow however I do
have three of these very beautiful and
very rare Paper Towns discussion guides
which I flagrantly stole from my
publisher and then like literally like
put in my shirt and walked out the
convention center so if anybody wants
one of these which actually will be
really helpful and interesting when you
read the book leave me a question in
comments that I can answer when I do one
of these next
by the way you guys like the paperback
cover of an abundance of katherines
coming out on August 8th for a mere
three dollars and 99 cents